cartoons are fun and sometimes they're
also super educational in some cases
they teach us about things that haven't
even happened yet whether it's the
Simpsons predicting the next president
or Zootopia anticipating the next
performance from a major star we can
look to cartoons for some clues about
where the world will take us next
so what fun surprising futuristic things
have cartoons accurately predicted about
our world stay tuned because we've
compiled a list of 10 of the coolest and
most accurate cartoon predictions in a
2017 episode of The Simpsons titled
serfs ins the cartoon most famously
known for predicting future events
managed to accurately predict a huge
Game of Thrones season 8 twist
insertions a game of Thrones themed
episode The Simpsons family stands on a
hill and watches as a dragon flies over
their town unleashing fire and burning
everything in its path the scene is
eerily similar to what happens in the
fifth episode of Game of Thrones season
8 which premiered two years after the
Simpsons prediction in the episode
titled the bells Daenerys and her forces
attack King's Landing leading to their
surrender but that isn't enough for
Danny she goes mad and lets her dragons
loose on the town the results look
almost identical to the Simpsons episode
complete with doom and gloom in a
village being burnt to the ground
Futurama has predicted a couple of
interesting things as well that are
becoming more and more mainstream like
their risk computers which are basically
just smartwatches but one of the most
interesting predictions appeared in the
1999 episode the series has landed while
at an amusement park on the moon the
Planet Express crew visits a video
arcade someone is playing skee-ball
while someone else is playing the
virtual skee-ball and mimicking the
motions of throwing an actual skee-ball
but the real punchline is the next
person they see who is playing virtual
virtual skee-ball basically they're just
sitting in a chair and doing nothing
with a cool headset on we can't deny
that this looks very similar to vr
gaming today even the headset bears a
remarkable resemblance to popular VR
headsets and as we're sitting in a chair
and doing nothing some of the VR that
exists today is just for a cool
experience and not so much for physical
gameplay so future Imus joke isn't so
far off from our reality The Simpsons
don't just accurately predict television
show twists they also know a thing or
two about movie studios all the way back
in 1998 The Simpsons aired an episode
called when you dish upon a star in the
episode a sign is showed on
thing that reads 20th century-fox a
division of the Walt Disney Company
almost 20 years later in 2017 Disney
officially announced a fifty two point
four billion dollar purchase that would
allow them to acquire twentieth
century-fox as well as national
geographic effects regional sports
networks and other assets funny enough
the Simpsons were just trying to poke
fun at their parent company Fox with
this one but later the Simpsons would
actually be streaming exclusively on
Disney plus we could chalk this guess up
to the showrunners understanding that
huge companies often merge and change
over time but it's still an incredibly
impressive Perdition to have made so far
in advance of the actual event but this
type of unbelievable prediction isn't
new for the Simpsons we have some even
crazier ones a little further down on
our list
Shakira put on an amazing halftime show
at the Super Bowl 54 but what's extra
cool about her performance is that it
bears a striking resemblance to another
of Shakira's performances but in that
one she was playing a gazelle in the
2016 animated film Zootopia Shakira
voices a pop superstar known as gazelle
when she performs for a crowd of animal
fans she's wearing a shimmery red outfit
complete with tassels for added movement
and flow Shakira's outfit at the
Superbowl was almost identical she even
had on the high red boots and both
versions of Shakira danced across the
stage with lots of movement and energy
so did Shakira actually take inspiration
directly from rizzuto Pia character it's
possible and Zootopia she's an icon that
brings animals together and she pretty
much did the same thing by performing on
the iconic Super Bowl stage if JLo had
also voiced the pop superstar on
Zootopia this Perdition would have been
even more epic Zootopia wasn't the only
animation to have a thing or two to say
about the Superbowl halftime shows and
the 2012 episode called Lisa goes gaga
The Simpsons displayed a very accurate
visual prediction of what Lady Gaga's
2017 Super Bowl halftime show would look
like in the episode Lady Gaga is
actually playing a Springfield concert
but she descends from the sky on wires
while wearing a harness and a glittery
silver outfit during her 2017 halftime
show Lady Gaga dropped down onto the
stage in a similar way and was wearing a
sparkly Versace number that was almost a
perfect match for the one who Simpsons
character wore and if that's not enough
she was flanked by drones in the sky
just as her character was during the
Springfield concert sure Lady Gaga is
known for some crazy stage antics and
fashion moments but she had never really
gone airborne or worn an outfit like
this before her Super Bowl performance
maybe the Simpsons knows Lady Gaga
better than she knows herself another
celebrity that the Simpson seems to know
pretty well is Donald Trump in an
episode that aired in 2000 called Bart
to the Future Lisa finds herself
becoming the next president of the
United States
she tells her team that they inherited
quite the budget crunch from President
Trump Trump would later go on to win the
presidency in real life in 2016 but the
prediction wasn't completely out of
nowhere back in 2000 Trump had already
revealed his intentions to one day run
for the presidency and the Simpsons
showrunners thought he would be a funny
choice for the episodes former president
but they never hoped he would actually
win a week after the election they
referenced their trump tradition in the
episodes chalkboard gag with a simple
line being write sucks The Simpsons had
a few more things to say about elections
in the 19th Treehouse of Horror episode
that aired in 2008 the show decided to
make some voter commentary connected to
the 2008 election when Homer goes into a
voting booth and chooses Barack Obama
the system automatically counts his vote
as being for John McCain while this
voting malfunction didn't occur during
the 2008 election a 2012 viral video
showed a voting booth in Pennsylvania
doing the same thing with Barack Obama
and Mitt Romney whenever the voter would
press Obama a checkmark would
automatically appear beside Romney's
name the voter repeatedly presses Obama
with the same results voting
malfunctions have been a topic of
conversation for many elections but the
Simpsons got this particular incident
almost exactly right with Obama being on
the losing side of both malfunctions
since there were a lot of reported
voting malfunctions and fraud in the
2016 election we imagine that this might
not be the only time the Simpsons voting
predictions will prove to be true in a
1999 episode titled the lesser of two
evils
Futurama managed to predict a pretty
surprising onstage mix-up in the episode
Zapp Brannigan is the judge of the Miss
Universe 3001 pageant when he has to
announce the winner he sees Leela off
stage and mistakenly says her name
instead of the one in the envelope
there's some confusion because she's not
even in the pageant but it's cleared up
when Zapp fixes his mistake and Gladys
Lennox is rightfully crowned the winner
Steve Harvey's major announcement
mistake during the 2015 Miss Universe
pageant is pretty similar to zaps but at
least he said the name of some
actually in the competition Harvey at
first declared miss Colombia the winner
and the pageant before realizing that he
misread the card he was forced to fix
his error and give the crown to Miss
Philippines but not until Miss Colombia
had a brief moment to celebrate the
mix-up caused a lot of mixed emotions
for the contestants and the audience and
made Steve Harvey a major newsworthy
topic and while you can say that zaps
mistake was a bit more foolish Harvey's
mistake was probably worse because he
had to disappoint someone who actually
was in the competition an underground
Kentucky Fried Chicken market seems like
it would never happen right well think
again because South Park actually got
this woman right while the idea is
pretty outrageous and is probably the
craziest on our list South Park
accurately predicted the existence of a
secret fried chicken market in 2010
during their medicinal fried chicken
episode the episode was originally based
on a KFC that was replaced in LA leading
to a bunch of outraged residents who
wanted their chicken back when this
event happened in South Park residents
went to extreme measures to make sure
they could get their fried chicken fix
Carmen developed a lucrative black
market where buckets of fried chicken
could be sold secretly to residents in
need of the fried food eight years later
this nightmare would become a reality in
the UK when 75% of KFC locations closed
for a period of a few days due to
unforeseen operational issues people
were unable to wait for the reopening
and began to buy buckets of KFC on eBay
that were being sold for as much as $100
each we don't even think South Park
realized how accurate this crazy idea
could be if a huge KFC shortage were to
actually occur South Park got another
prediction mostly right in 2008 in an
episode titled Brittany's a new look a
news anchor guessed that Miley Cyrus
would be pops next big megastar but he
also guessed that she would be the next
star to go off the rails similar to
Britney Spears 2007 meltdown hearing
this the people of South Park decide
that Miley Cyrus is their next big
obsession in 2008 Miley was only 16 and
still starring in the hit Disney Channel
series Hannah Montana but after the show
wrapped production Miley's creative
ventures took a turn that had people
questioning whether or not she was
headed for a downward spiral
first there was a revealing magazine
cover shoot the pole dance of the VMAs
and then her rebellious phase during the
early 2010's
with the release of party songs like we
can't stop from her bangers album
Miley even admitted that achieving
at such a young age you made her feel
like she had to find herself and rebell
a little bit but rebelling bought her
more into the public eye than ever
before
so while Miley didn't have a straight-up
meltdown and a career is still doing
pretty well South Park definitely
predicted her rise to super stardom and
the bad public behavior that came along
with it so while the things that these
cartoons predict may not be completely
accurate a hundred percent of the time
we have to admit that there have been
some pretty close calls in terms of
showrunners guessing what will happen in
the future
what prediction impressed you the most
and what are some other predictions
you've noticed in your favorite cartoons
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe to things for more
great content
[Music]
[Music]